[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre magazine
de l'éducation comment s'organise des
journées des 12 millions d'élèves qui
chaque matin se rendent à l'école au
collège ou au lycée et quels sont les
méthodes de leurs enseignants ne bougez
pas vous allez tout savoir grâce à
liberté égalité scolarité et voici tout
de suite le sommaire
[Musique]
le dispositif
Ulysse ou comment inclure dans l'école
les enfants souffrant de handicap nous
sommes allés voir comment cela
fonctionne dans un collège de l'Allier
il existe 300 internats d'excellence en
France qui offrent aux élèves un
environnement privilégié pour mieux
étudier encadrer tous les soirs du lundi
au vendredi pour un avenir meilleur
transformer la cour de récré bétonnée en
oasis c'est ce que propose une
association dans les écoles parisiennes
et bien entendu ce sont les élèves qui
sont les mieux placés pour dessiner la
cour de leurs rêves et enfin retour en
archives sur les cours d'éducation
civique vous allez le voir
l'enseignement des valeurs de la
République a bien évolué au fil des ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on entend souvent parler d'école
inclusive sont toujours savoir ce que
cela signifie concrètement et bien ici
au collège Victor Hugo de saint-yor dans
l'Académie de Clermont-Ferrand on
accueille très élèves dans les troubles
et handicaps prendre difficile une
scolarité parfaitement ordinaire alors
pour prendre en compte leur singularité
le collège les intègre dans un
dispositif d'unité localisé pour
l'Inclusion Scolaire un dispositif
Ulysse comme il en existe
10272 sur tout le territoire vous allez
le voir l'objectif est évidemment d'en
faire des élèves parfaitement intégrés
au collège
[Musique]
bonjour madame Louis bonjour merci de
nous accueillir dans votre classe
Ulysse spécifique aux élèves Ulysse
c'est ça c'est bien ça alors c'est un
dispositif on les élèves sont dans leur
classe et moi je les accueille quand
justement ils ont besoin de reprendre
leur cours ou de suivre leur programme
de maths français ou selon où ils en
sont à leur niveau mais on n'est pas
vraiment une classe à part entière on
est vraiment un groupe d'élèves qui ont
des besoins particuliers et qui
bénéficie d'être supplémentaires pour
pouvoir suivre un parcours le plus
ordinaire possible on va dire et donc là
c'est les petits sixième que vous allez
voir voilà donc nos 6e qui ont besoin de
revoir la physique comprendre
l'alternance jour nuit et les saisons là
comme on a le soleil de ce côté
ça fait la lumière ici donc là nous on
est dans la nuit
après sa tourne on est là du coup ça va
être le par exemple le midi c'est le
jour et la terre hop elle tourne elle
tourne elle tourne vas-y elle tourne ça
tourne ça tourne ça tourne ça tourne
super
elle tourne autour du soleil ça va
est-ce que vous savez en combien de
temps elles tournent autour du soleil
non 24 heures c'est sur elle-même
combien de temps on va mettre pour faire
tout le tour du soleil il est énorme
notre Soleil faut pas l'oublier c'est
immense alors combien de temps la Terre
va mettre de temps pour faire tout le
tour
allez venez vous rasoir vous avez bien
fait le Soleil et la Terre est-ce que
vous avez mieux compris ce qui se passe
dans notre système solaire là oui
qu'on comprenne un petit peu ce qui se
passe avec la sixième là vous faites
face à quel type de handicap on est tous
sur des troubles cognitifs donc on va
avoir des dysfonctionnements de la
mémoire de la tension de la
concentration on va avoir aussi des
troubles des orthographiques dyslexiques
plus ou moins handicapant et on a aussi
un élève donc qui a du troubles du
spectre tristique est-ce que vous dans
votre formation vous avez donc appris à
qui des choses spécifiques pour faire
face à ce type de difficultés oui vous
n'êtes pas une professeure comme les
autres non j'ai une certification
supplémentaire donc j'ai je suis
enseignante spécialisée depuis 15 ans
maintenant
spécialisé dans les troupes cognitifs
même si on n'est pas psychologue il va
falloir utiliser des stratagèmes pour
réussir à les aider à dépasser ça pour
qu'il soit plus à l'aise dans
l'ordinaire
je vais m'assurer un petit peu si vous
avez réussi à mémoriser un petit peu
plus
[Musique]
est-ce que vous l'aimez bien le cours
avec Madame oui oui vous la voyez
combien de fois par semaine
beaucoup
[Musique]
c'était à peu près plusieurs fois par
semaine en tout cas
le mardi 1h est-ce que si je vous dis
Ulysse vous savez ce que c'est ou pas du
tout oui c'est quoi c'est ce qui c'est
les enfants qui ont des difficultés
exactement et après quand vous avez fini
le cours avec Madame oui qu'est-ce que
vous faites vous allez où
c'est avec les autres élèves OK et
comment ça se passe avec les autres
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on a qu'une heure on va pas
faire beaucoup de choses nouvelles nos
petits parcours pour se réveiller allez
venez dedans dehors dedans dehors c'est
presque ça
fini celui-là et puis je viens de
t'aider là regarde toutes petites
différences
1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 tu essayes un deux
trois un deux trois ça y est tu as le
rythme
comment ça se fait que si tu ne sers pas
assez
c'est aussi ce genre d'attention que
vous avez un petit peu en plus
est-ce que vous adaptez vos cours ou pas
spécialement
c'est plus dans la façon de faire passer
les consignes je pense parce que j'ai
pas besoin de dire à la plupart des
élèves je vais peut-être essayer de
trouver d'autres façons d'expliquer ce
qu'il y a à faire avec ses élèves
vas-y Mélanie ça marche
mais ça marche
j'aime bien quand on t'explique aussi
quand Eva elle t'explique oui c'est plus
facile parfois ouais la classe en fait
tout le monde est un peu tout le monde
ok ok et tu fais ça naturellement ou
parfois les profs ils vous disent il
faut aider par exemple
[Musique]
le vocabulaire j'ai bien votre
vocabulaire schématisation vous êtes au
point sur les deux donc là il demande de
le fléchir donc on flèche le sens du
courant qui va de plus vers le point à
l'extérieur du générateur
tu vois la diode qui roule tu as un
câble regarde
tu as la pile le symbole de la pile et
tu repars de l'autre côté alors
ils sont où les exercices ils sont là
[Musique]
deux trois on a une qui est absente
d'accord ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on les
laisse se placer où ils veulent et après
on voit comment ça fonctionne là dans
une autre classe il y a un élève qui a
été dont la jeune fille qui était à côté
a dit il est fatiguant il est
envahissant donc on a changé de patient
aucun problème alors là donc du coup
qu'est-ce que là vous regardez un peu le
carnet de non pas c'est des devoirs à
noter
et pour rajables l'écriture est très
difficile d'accord mal d'accord il écrit
mal d'accord on écrit à sa place
d'animer votre classe avec ces élèves
plus particuliers peut-être pas du tout
l'aide de Marie est très précieuse parce
que c'est souvent au niveau de
l'écriture de la prise de cours où il y
a un petit décalage qui se fait démarrer
là pour bien compenser
décalage derrière qu'est-ce que ça
apporte à votre classe d'avoir trois
éléments d'un dispositif à part c'est un
apprentissage en quelque sorte de la
différence
[Musique]
on reprend le texte on va le finir du
coup on a fait juste la première partie
hier voilà quels sont les signes qu'on
peut repérer là dans le texte qui nous
montre que c'est du dialogue
oui très bien les guillemets et
qu'est-ce qu'on se dit en premier
bonjour donc là le début du dialogue il
est où
bah ouais tu sais pourquoi tu es dans ce
dispositif toi
pourquoi
j'arrive pas à faire du français
quand on t'a proposé de travailler avec
Madame Bouygues
des autres copains dans les classes
[Musique]
vous mettez les chaises avant de partir
s'il vous plaît sur les tables pour que
le ménage puisse être fait
la bonne soirée à demain
on a pu interroger et assez facilement
vos élèves certains ne se sont peut-être
pas vraiment à leur place est-ce que
vous avez voilà vous entendez ça aussi
enfin tout à fait parce que c'est très
compliqué pour eux à accepter de se dire
qu'on est différent alors qu'on a envie
d'être comme tout le monde on fait tout
pour qu'il soit dans le milieu ordinaire
et on fait tout pour qu'ils se sente
bien et comme les autres c'est
finalement un autre regard pour tout le
monde dans l'établissement que l'on soit
ordinaire ou dans un dispositif
particulier on a un autre regard on a la
fiche qui est devant ma classe elle m'a
vraiment parlé quand je l'ai vu je me
suis dit c'est ça c'est avoir un autre
regard sur les enfants sur
l'enseignement on a l'impression de
regarder le monde autrement quoi
[Musique]
il existe plus de 300 internats
d'excellence répartis sur tout le
territoire ils permettent à des
collégiens ou des lycéens en difficulté
sociale familiales ou économiques de
retrouver un cadre de vie pour réussir
au mieux leurs études ici au lycée
Jacques FEDER d'Épinay-sur-Seine ils
sont une vingtaine d'élèves à avoir
choisi cette formule et consonne la fin
des courses c'est là que commence leur
vie interne un peu comme une deuxième
famille dans laquelle on va se glisser
suivez nous
[Musique]
merci de nous accueillir dans le lycée
Jacques FEDER qui a une spécificité
puisqu'on possède un internat
d'excellence à l'ouverture on avait
seulement 5 élèves et aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui on est à une vingtaine
d'élèves ils ont en plus donc de leur
journée de travail on va dire comme les
autres élèves du lycée ils ont des
études de surveiller encadrés voilà et
ils ont beaucoup de soutien scolaire
puisque voilà ils en ont besoin ils ont
donc un bâtiment qui leur est dédié oui
vous allez voir que c'est vraiment un
cadre qui est très agréable pour les
élèves très bien vous allez nous montrer
tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour
donc là on est dans la grande salle de
travail d'études voilà qui est toujours
encadrée en tout cas sur les premières
heures alors tu te souviens des
principes qu'il faut pas oublier c'est à
dire que c'est comme en anglais oui ça
passe
est-ce que toi depuis que tu es ici
depuis la rentrée là de la seconde tu te
dis je travaille beaucoup plus souvent
en tout cas beaucoup mieux que si
j'avais été chez moi
ça c'est sûr à 100% j'ai pas vraiment la
discipline j'ai besoin
à 7h je dois travailler et ça j'arrive
pas à le faire chez moi au moins mon
avenir il est un peu mieux s'assurer que
j'ai mon je sais que je travaille pas
même cette année l'année dernière
c'était notamment quand je rentre chez
moi
et là du coup en seconde même si ça
paraît pas énorme
je te confirme
comment tu as décidé de t'inscrire bah
personnellement en fait moi je suis
quelqu'un qui vit dans qui déménage
souvent et ça veut dire que cette
fois-ci c'est trop petit pour nous et
donc je n'ai pas ma chambre je peux pas
vraiment concentré et ce que j'ai des
ambitions je vais aller loin dans mes
projets mes études donc là les filles va
falloir aller à la box donc vous posez
vos affaires et vous prenez vos tenues
pour qu'on y aille ensemble
[Musique]
ok donc là on va juste travailler pour
voir un peu les déplacements et la garde
après vous allez vous mettre deux par
deux
on va avoir des petites techniques
simples
[Musique]
pourquoi vous proposez autant
d'activités sportives aux internes alors
pour nous ça nous paraît essentiel
qu'elle se sente bien on vise quand même
nos objectifs c'est le bien-être on sait
aller mieux aller bien avoir une bonne
estime de soi c'est quand même important
pour pouvoir mieux travailler toutes ces
différentes activités vous les avez
pensé réfléchi sur l'année on essaye de
faire des choses sportives culturelles
on fait intervenir des associations des
partenaires d'accord sur la vingtaine
d'élèves qu'on suit depuis tout à
l'heure concrètement ce sont des
parcours
atypiques cabossés pas plus que ça c'est
assez hétérogène parfois certaines et
certains reviennent le lundi dans des
états qui sont pas toujours très faciles
à gérer on a aussi une assistante
sociale dans l'établissement qui a une
grosse part voilà qui reçoit les élèves
qui connaît les élèves voilà donc c'est
aussi très important l'aspect l'aspect
social ce qu'elles vivent et ce qu'ils
vivent chez eux
mais non
mince la provisoire adjointe vous là
vous voyez la maîtresse de d'internat
ok
j'ai gagné
les filles on va aller se coucher Go par
contre les filles vont manger la salle
s'il vous plaît merci
[Musique]
en quoi ça consiste d'être maîtresse
d'internat et bah du coup ça consiste
encadrer nos élèves donc de 17h20
jusqu'à 20 on va dire le lendemain matin
du coup ok vous dormez sur place
exactement c'est ça est-ce que vous avez
l'impression d'être un peu leur nounou
un petit peu ou un petit peu en fait à
ce temps d'éducation mais nous en même
temps parce que quand elles ont besoin
de parler je suis là elles ont des
petits soucis à me raconter du coup je
suis là également donc ça fait partie de
votre mission
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment ça se passe quand vous rentrez
chez vous le weekend on sent mieux ici
qu'à la maison
du matin mais j'ai tout contente de les
retrouver je sais que c'est comme ça je
veux rentrer maintenant
je suis plus proche des internes que ma
famille
les filles je prends le téléphone c'est
l'heure de dormir ah il est 22h30 là et
là tu peux brancher mon téléphone
bon bonne nuit les filles
[Musique]
nous sommes dans la cour de l'école
Lucienne dans le deuxième arrondissement
de Paris une cour avec de l'asphalte
beaucoup d'Asphalt mais depuis des
semaines les élèves travaillent avec les
urbanistes d'une association pour
transformer cette cour en oasis c'est un
projet mené par la Ville de Paris qui
vise à aménager cet espace de façon plus
ludique mais aussi plus écologique il
est l'heure du cinquième et dernier
atelier venez voir
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour alors expliquez-moi ce
que vous êtes en train de faire là alors
là on est en train de préparer le
matériel pour un atelier maquette on
leur donne un plan Vierge de la cour les
seuls éléments qui ne peuvent pas bouger
on va dire c'est les arbres OK et à eux
de d'imaginer comment on peut
transformer la cour ils ont réfléchi au
matériaux de sol aux différents
aménagements etc c'est un groupe de
délégués avec lesquels on travaille donc
c'est deux les deux délégués de chaque
classe des 7 classes de l'école donc ils
sont 14 bonjour
[Musique]
là vous avez
ici un socle c'est votre cours d'école à
vous d'ajouter tous les éléments de
votre projet
alors alors alors
comment ça avance cette maquette
c'est un peu compliqué à coller tu veux
je te le tienne un peu alors je vais le
tenir
je vois que vous mettez de l'herbe vous
mettez aussi des choses un peu
parce que
il y a que des béton ou des choses comme
ça et du coup quand il pleut l'eau elle
peut pas
s'évaporer dans dans la terre alors sauf
que là oui ça fait
quand même de faire une courroie une
cour oasis mais alors c'est quoi du coup
la cour oasis
sans être humide et rester toujours à la
plein de chaleur
n'hésitez pas à utiliser la colle en
bateau aussi c'est plus facilement
une rivière dans le jardin vous avez le
droit de tout faire on a décidé de
mettre des cabanes les étoiles dedans
c'est faux lecture ici il y a un
récupérateur d'eau avec de la végétation
qui grimpe ah ça ça c'est quoi ça le
récupérateur d'eau
pourquoi en béton blanc
ça absorbe moins la chaleur du coup ça
fera une cour où il fera moins chaud
alors marie-louis un petit peu c'est
quoi ce projet de cours oasis alors
c'est un projet qui est mené par la
Ville de Paris depuis 2017 en fait
l'idée c'est de leur faire comprendre
les enjeux du projet pourquoi ça les
touche directement et donc on parle
changement climatique du coup et
notamment des vagues de chaleur qui vont
s'intensifier et comment la ville peut
s'adapter la maîtrise d'ouvrage et la
maîtrise d'oeuvre sont faites par la par
la Ville de Paris directement donc c'est
la mairie de Paris qui finit les travaux
ok c'est ça combien de cours pour
l'instant
ont été réalisés alors à Paris il y a
une centaine de cours déjà qui ont été
réalisés vous avez combien de cours
encore en projet vous savez ça coûte
toutes les courbes vont être
transformées donc en tout il me semble
qu'il y a environ un peu plus de 600
cours d'école
[Musique]
bravo à tous vos maquettes elles sont
top vous pouvez venir les regarder avant
de partir
et les enfants qui veut venir me montrer
ce que ça va donner dans la cour allez
venez venez me montrer ça
Nina explique-moi
on avait proposé d'agrandir le la zone
du jardin ok
dessus Camille
avec deux tentes est-ce que tous ces
projets sont réalisables
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
liberté égalité fraternité mais aussi
laïcité telles sont les valeurs et les
fondements de la République dispensés
tout au long de l'année à l'école ces
cours ont souvent changé de nom de
contenu ils se sont adaptés aux époques
retour en archives avec le réseau canopé
sur des décennies d'instruction civiques
et comme souvent ça commence avec Jules
Ferry
respecter les autres les écouter savoir
demander pardon assumer ses actes tout
cela n'a malheureusement rien d'évident
des hussards noirs de la Troisième
République aux années 2010 marquées par
les attentats la formation de l'élève
citoyen a beaucoup changé retour sur
quelques épisodes de cette histoire
mouvementée 28 mars 1882 coûte tonnerre
Jules Ferry tape du point sur la table
l'instruction morale et religieuse et
remplacée par l'instruction morale et
civique fini la régence de l'église
cette instruction dans la toute jeune 3e
république comporte pour nous un volet
inattendu les exercices militaires
disciplines respect de la hiérarchie
amour de la patrie voilà l'élève soldat
Paris pour l'avenir un avenir qui se
résumera bientôt en trois mots Première
Guerre mondiale
mais faisons un grand bon en avant année
50 les exercices militaires ont disparu
c'est surtout la morale qu'on retrouve
en tête d'affiche instruire c'est édifié
et en effet c'était différent année 70
alors que les années Flower Power sont à
peine fanées deux chocs pétroliers
viennent coup sur coup heurter le pays
de nouvelles problématiques apparaissent
des sujets qui ont de l'avenir
en 1977 sur fond de crise apparaît dans
les collèges l'initiation à la vie
économique et sociale
de l'économie et du social la politique
n'est pas loin bonjour monsieur le
Président de la République à quoi sert
un président
au lycée il faudra attendre 1999 pour
voir naître l'éducation civique
juridique et sociale qui s'appuiera sur
la méthodologie du débat année 2000 tous
accélère le 8 juillet 2013 les vacances
commencent bien la loi Peillon refonte
l'école de la République bienvenue à
l'enseignement moral et civique et par
morale on entend moral laïque et tout
bascule le 7 janvier 2015 avec
l'attentat contre Charlie Hebdo en s'en
prenant à la liberté de la presse c'est
la République qu'on attaque à compter de
2016 pour tous les élèves de l'école au
lycée l'éducation morale et civique
s'inscrit au cœur d'un parcours citoyen
apprendre à réfléchir de manière
raisonnée débattre argumenter développer
un esprit critique sont quelques-uns des
jalons de ce parcours citoyen
la communauté éducative est à présent
appelée à se mobiliser si changer les
mots c'est déjà changé sa façon
d'envisager le monde c'est diverses
dénominations ont en commun une même
ambition un peu plus d'égalité un peu
plus de fraternité pour tous et pour
chacun et chacune avez-vous des
questions à poser oui on pourrait se
demander ceci entre nécessité et urgence
l'éducation civique ne fait-elle jamais
autre chose que commencer toujours
recommencer étant donné l'importance
renouvelée des enjeux il est
indispensable de transmettre un socle de
valeur pour nourrir les citoyens de
demain
[Musique]
je suis égale à toi j'avais une fille à
la tour
[Musique]
et voilà l'émission est déjà terminée
mais on se retrouve très vite pour un
prochain numéro de liberté égalité
scolarité